next we're talking about weddings uh
ross i know you're planning one so we'll
get your take in just a bit okay okay
metro reports that even with the
challenges of planning a wedding in the
pandemic couples still feel the pressure
to invite people they do not like a
british study found 83 percent of those
people invited unwanted guests to their
special day many said the undesired
guest often a plus one of someone they
genuinely like or a family member ross
you're making a wedding happen soon how
do you feel about this well i'm
literally well thank you hi yes i am
literally like putting together the
invite list right now and so i feel this
it's pain because i never thought about
it before but did you know that weddings
can be very
expensive and so as i'm putting the list
together i'm like i like you but i don't
like love you
i don't like you
you know like i think you're great but
um so you literally swiping left on the
invitation list
yeah and you know you know me like i'm
nice but i am brutal when it comes to
this invite list girl just face facts if
we're not close you're not coming all
right
[Laughter]
where are you at with it like how do you
where do you feel at your peace like
where's your boundaries well i i i we're
putting it together now the truth is you
know growing up as a little farm kid in
a farm town i never thought i'd get to
have a wedding you know i never saw gay
people
grown up marrying because it wasn't
allowed and wellington my fiance is an
immigrant from dominican republic
he didn't imagine this future for us and
so now the fact that we do get to get
married married is so beautiful and i
can i brag for just a little second yeah
no one's seen this yet but this is the
latest issue of sophisticated weddings
magazine and wellington and i are the
very first same-sex couple ever featured
in the magazine
[Applause]
and i
and i think about
i think about you know just kids around
anywhere now can look at this and know
that they are equal and they are worthy
and they can be fabulous too
[Music]